Pas de doute inspecteur
c'est un homicide
Il y a environ 10 000 ans au Proche-Orient,
certains humains ont cessé d’être nomades
et sont devenus peu à peu des agriculteurs.
Cette évolution, qu’on a souvent décrite comme une révolution,
la fameuse “révolution
néolithique”
a transformé les sociétés en profondeur.
Architecture, techniques, alimentation,
richesse, pouvoir
tout a changé.
Les idées et les croyances aussi.
Malheureusement pour
les préhistoriens, il est très difficile de savoir
ce que les gens avaient dans la
tête.
Comme on ne possède pas de texte à cette époque,
il faut se baser sur d’autres
indices :
l’art et les symboles.
Le symbole le plus répandu au début de la
révolution néolithique est sans conteste le bovin.
Peint, gravé ou sous forme de crâne,
il est partout.
On considère souvent qu’il représente un symbole masculin et
associé
à des figures féminines qu’on connaît
sous forme de statuettes notamment, ils formeraient
le premier couple divin, à la base des religions postérieures.
C’est en tout cas ce que
beaucoup d’archéologues ont postulé, dans
la lignée de l’archéologue français Jacques
Cauvin. Pour lui, c’est la manifestation
d’une grande “révolution des symboles”,
qui précède et accompagne la révolution néolithique.
A y regarder de plus près toutefois, le thème
des bovins est déjà largement développé
avant le Néolithique : bisons et aurochs
ont été représentés dans des dizaines
de grottes du Paléolithique. Tout comme le
thème féminin d’ailleurs, on connaît
de très nombreuses statuettes de “Vénus”
et le Néolithique ne semble pas avoir inventé
grand-chose de ce point de vue là.
Alors il ne s’agit pas de dire que Cauvin se trompait
complètement, bien sûr il savait tout ça
et il décrit plutôt une nouvelle manière
de représenter ces symboles dans des nouveaux
contextes. Mais il y a bien une évolution
des symboles au Néolithique, notamment avec
l'apparition de thèmes inconnus des ancêtres
chasseurs-cueilleurs. Parmi eux, il y a un
symbole récurrent, qui a obsédé les humains
pendant plus de 4000 ans dans une bonne partie
du Proche-Orient : les crânes humains et
les vautours.
La première fois qu’on a repéré ce symbole,
c’était dans les années 1960, dans le
sud de la Turquie, au village néolithique
de Çatal Höyük. Les fouilles ont mis au
jour des centaines de maisons en terre datant
du VIIe millénaire avant J.-C. Elles étaient
construites les unes contre les autres et
on y accédait par les toits. Certaines d’entre
elles étaient richement décorées, avec
des reliefs ou des peintures. En plus de nombreux
bovins, et de quelques figures féminines,
l’archéologue britannique James Mellaart
exhume dans plusieurs maisons des peintures
murales qui montrent de grands vautours. Avec
leur silhouette menaçante, ailes déployées,
ils ont l’air tout droit sortis d’un cauchemar,
d’autant qu’ils sont réunis autour de
corps humains sans tête et semblent les attaquer.
Sur le sol, en bas d’une des peintures,
était déposé un crâne humain.
Scène exceptionnelle dans le très riche
décor de Çatal Höyük où les bovins et
les panthères sont majoritaires, le thème
des vautours et des crânes intrigue les préhistoriens.
Dans les décennies suivantes, d’autres
découvertes alimentent le mystère.
Plus à l’est, dans la haute vallée de
l’Euphrate, le site de Nevalı Çori, a livré plusieurs sculptures de vautours
posés sur des têtes humaines, ou associés
à des corps. Sous les maisons du site, les
archéologues ont retrouvé des dépôts d’ossements,
notamment des crânes qui avaient fait l’objet
d’une attention particulière, l’un d’eux
était même posé sur un couteau en silex.
Enfin, certaines sépultures du site avaient
des crânes manquants.
Cette pratique est connue dans de nombreux
autres sites de la région, comme à Körtik
Tepe et Çatal Höyük dont on vient de parler.
Les fouilles récentes du site, dans les années
1990, ont repéré des marques de coupe sur
des vertèbres. Une planche en bois était
posée sur le corps pour s’appuyer dessus
pendant l’opération.
Plus bas dans la vallée de l’Euphrate,
le site de Jerf el Ahmar est d’un apport
considérable. Fouillé à la fin des années
1990 par les équipes de Danielle Stordeur,
il a livré des représentations de corps
sans tête et de vautours. Dans l’un des
bâtiments communautaires, ces grandes salles
semi-enterrées qui ont fait la renommée
du site, une dalle décorée de trois corps
sans tête était encadrée par deux têtes
de vautour sculptées. Plus impressionnant,
au sol, un corps sans tête d’une jeune
femme était étendu sur le dos, les bras
en croix. Cette mise en scène macabre, réalisée
avant la destruction volontaire du bâtiment,
est complétée par le dépôt de crânes
au fond de trous de poteaux.
A Göbekli Tepe, célébrissime sanctuaire du tout premier Néolithique,
en plus des
nombreuses représentations d’animaux sauvages
et menaçants, le pilier n°43 montre plusieurs
vautours et un homme sans tête.
Une petite figurine interprétée comme un vautour a
aussi été trouvée sur place.
On pourrait continuer d’égrener les trouvailles
de ce type. Le site de Nemrik en Irak a livré
des représentations de vautours et des crânes
isolés.
A Mureybet, en Syrie, un crâne était posé sur un support en argile,
le site d’Hacılar en Turquie livre quatre
crânes isolés et à Çayönü, ce sont 71
crânes qui ont été mis au jour dans un seul bâtiment
Ailleurs, notamment dans la vallée du Jourdain,
les crânes sont même utilisés pour confectionner
de véritables reliques. A Tell Aswad, Beisamoun,
‘Ain Ghazal, Jéricho et d’autres sites
de la région, les humains du Néolithique
ont reconstitué des visages avec du plâtre et de l’argile.
C’est ce qu’on appelle
les crânes surmodelés.
Déposés en groupe dans des fosses, ils sont à mettre en relation
avec les sépultures sans tête trouvées à proximité.
A Kfar HaHoresh, en Israël,
de nombreuses sépultures sans crâne sont
trouvées sous des couches de sol en plâtre,
ce qui fait penser que les crânes servent
de dépôt de fondation avant la construction
des bâtiments. A ‘Ain Ghazal, en Jordanie,
des sépultures sans crâne mais présentant
encore la mâchoire, montrent que le crâne
a été prélevé après décomposition du
corps.
Un peu plus tard, cette pratique est aussi
documentée en Turquie. A Köşk Höyük,
sur dix-neuf crânes retrouvés sous les sols
des maisons, treize portaient des traces de
plâtre, parfois coloré. Sur ce site, on
possède aussi des squelettes sans leur crâne
mais avec leur mâchoire. Un crâne surmodelé
était aussi présent dans une tombe à Çatal Höyük,
dans les bras d’une femme inhumée.
Le crâne était couvert de plusieurs couches de pigment rouge.
On le voit, il se passe quelque chose au Néolithique
au Proche-Orient avec les vautours, et surtout
avec les crânes. En plus, tous les sites
archéologiques qu’on a mentionnés ne sont
pas contemporains et ils montrent que cette
obsession a perduré pendant au moins quatre
millénaire, en gros, entre 10 000 et 6 000 avant J.-C.
Bien sûr, les archéologues ont
proposé de nombreuses théories pour essayer
d’expliquer ça, il y en a quatre principales.
Dès la découverte de la première peinture
de vautours à Çatal Höyük, James Mellaart
fait le rapprochement avec les Tours du silence.
Ces édifices, qu’on nomme dakhmâ en farsi,
servaient chez les mazdéistes d’Iran, c’est
une religion, à exposer certains cadavres
pour qu’ils soient dévorés par les vautours.
C’est un rituel assez rare mais qui a frappé
l’imagination des étrangers depuis longtemps.
Lors de la découverte des structures mégalithiques de Göbekli Tepe,
certains pensent aussi à
cette possibilité. Après tout, les cercles
de pierre sont situés en hauteur, loin d’une
source d’eau et auraient été facilement
repérables pour les oiseaux. C’est à mettre
en lien avec la trouvaille en grande quantité
d’ossements de corbeaux, qui représentent
plus de la moitié des restes de faune à
Göbekli Tepe, et des ossements d'autres animaux
charognards, dont les vautours.
Mellaart imaginait même que tous les corps
retrouvés sous les maisons de Çatal Höyük
avaient préalablement été décharnés par
les charognards, mais l’analyse précise
des squelettes dément aujourd’hui complètement
cette hypothèse. D’autant que Mellaart
omet de mentionner l’absence de têtes sur
les peintures et le fait que la plupart des
inhumés ont encore leur tête. Si ce sont
bien des rites funéraires qui sont représentés,
ils ne concernaient pas toute la population.
Associé au serpent, symbole très présent
aussi à cette époque, comme sur un galet
gravé de Jerf el Ahmar ou les piliers de
Göbekli Tepe, le vautour aurait pu jouer
le rôle de passeur entre les mondes. Le serpent
est en lien avec l’inframonde, et le vautour
avec le ciel. Il aurait donc un rôle psychopompe,
faisant passer les âmes vers l’au-delà.
Cela a fait pencher certains archéologues
pour la théorie d’une religion de type
chamanique au Néolithique. Pourquoi pas.
Dans cette perspective, les restes de vautours
sur les sites auraient pu servir à élaborer
des costumes. C’est en tout cas ce que suggère
l’étude réalisée par l’archéozoologue
Lionel Gourichon pour le site de Jerf el Ahmar.
Après une étude minutieuse des restes osseux,
il semble que le vautour n’a pas été abattu
pour sa chair à la différence des autres
oiseaux. Les traces de découpe se concentrent
sur les ailes et le crâne, sans doute pour
exploiter des plumes et fabriquer des habits
cérémoniels. Des traces similaires sont
présentes sur le site de Pınarbaşı.
De quoi relire différemment les peintures
de Çatal Höyük : les deux vautours munis
de jambes étrangement humaines autour d’un
homme sans tête, sont peut-être des prêtres
déguisés,
en train de réaliser un rituel funéraire.
Une deuxième hypothèse assez évidente en
ce qui concerne les crânes prélevés dans
les tombes, est le culte des ancêtres. La
pratique du surmodelage serait alors un moyen
de conserver les traits et le souvenir du
défunt. Les crânes retrouvés enterrés
correspondraient dès lors à des objets désaffectés,
ayant fini leur vie de relique après la dernière
étape d’un parcours rituel. A ‘Ain Ghazal
et Jéricho, les deux crânes retrouvés sur
le sol de maisons incendiées, étaient peut-être
des reliques toujours en activité, détruites dans un incendie accidentel.
L’archéologue Catherine Perlès fait le
point sur cette théorie
elle rappelle qu’aucune sépulture sans tête n’existe en contexte
paléolithique, et que le phénomène apparaît
en revanche dès le Natoufien au Proche-Orient,
c’est-à-dire dans les premières sociétés sédentaires.
Elle y voit la naissance d’une
filiation territorialisée, de dynasties locales
en quelque sorte, honorées par un culte des
ancêtres.
De quoi relire une autre peinture de Çatal
Höyük. Sur la scène de chasse au cerf d’une
des maisons, trois personnages, sans tête,
et parfois de couleur différente, pourraient
être des ancêtres héroïques participant
à la chasse avec les vivants.
Cette troisième hypothèse est proposée
par Alain Testart, un anthropologue qui nous
a beaucoup inspiré et qu’on a déjà beaucoup
cité sur cette chaîne. D’après lui, la
symbolique des vautours et des crânes n’est
pas une expression d’un rite funéraire
ou d’un culte des ancêtres, mais plutôt de la guerre.
Car même si quelques sociétés
ont utilisé les vautours pour leurs rites
funéraires, cela reste extrêmement rare.
Et aucune ne décapite préalablement les
défunts. Le vautour et la décapitation sont
d’habitude associés à des cadavres abandonnés
sans sépulture, en général des ennemis
vaincus. L’iconographie plus tardive du
Proche-Orient le rappelle : en Mésopotamie,
la Stèle des vautours qui date du 2450 avant
J.-C., ou en Egypte, la Palette de Narmer,
sept cents ans plus tôt, montrent des ennemis
nus, décapités et dont certains sont dévorés
par les oiseaux. Il ne s’agit pas d’un
rituel, mais bien d’un massacre.
Pour Testart, il est improbable de représenter
un rite funéraire aussi macabre sur le mur
d’une maison comme à Çatal Höyük. En
Iran, les tours du silence sont des lieux
impurs et interdits d’accès, on ne les
représente pas. Les peintures funéraires
représentent en revanche le défunt dans
toute sa gloire, en train de festoyer ou de
chasser, mais certainement pas sans tête
et en train de se faire dévorer. Cette représentation
doit donc avoir à faire avec le prestige
d’avoir tué des ennemis, ce qui est beaucoup
plus courant.
On peut à nouveau en trouver un écho à
Çatal Höyük. Les fresques seraient donc
des souvenirs d’exploits guerriers, et les
crânes trouvés à proximité pourraient
être ceux d’ennemis, rapportés en trophée,
comme cela existe chez de nombreux peuples
qui ont pratiqué la chasse aux têtes. Cela
pourrait être en adéquation avec une autre
peinture du site, malheureusement très mal
préservée. On y voit une tête avec les
yeux fermés, qui semble avoir été porté
par un personnage dont seul le torse est préservé.
C’est peut-être la plus vieille représentation
au monde d’une tête coupée.
En suivant cette hypothèse, le bâtiment
de Çayönü qui a livré 71 crânes serait
donc un lieu dédié aux trophées de guerre.
La majorité de ces crânes, qui étaient
alignés sur des étagères de bois avant
que le bâtiment ne brûle, semblent avoir
appartenu à de jeunes hommes, et dix d’entre
eux, à des enfants. Improbable pour un culte
des ancêtres, mais plausible pour une chasse
aux têtes…
Enfin, dernière hypothèse, il n’est pas
à exclure que ces crânes soient des vestiges
de sacrifices humains. Il y a en particulier
un site qui permet de l’envisager, c’est
Domuztepe, en Turquie. Ce site tardif a livré
notamment une poterie décorée qui illustre
le même thème des vautours et corps sans tête.
Les humains sont allongés nus par
terre sans leur tête et sont entourés par
des oiseaux schématisés, peut-être des
vautours. Une tête semble être représentée
à côté du corps en bas et un humain à
droite est debout, vêtu. Il pourrait s’agir
d’une représentation d’un chef victorieux
au combat, dominant ses ennemis vaincus, ou
bien… il pourrait s’agir d’autre chose.
Car à Domuztepe, les archéologues ont fait
une découverte particulièrement macabre.
Une grande fosse a livré des ossements d’au
moins trente-cinq humains mélangés avec
ceux de chèvres, moutons, porcs, bovins et
chiens. Les ossements humains présentaient
par ailleurs de nombreuses traces de coups
et de découpe : désarticulés, raclés et
même brisés pour en extraire la moëlle,
ils évoquent clairement des sacrifices avec
une pratique de cannibalisme rituel. A côté
de la fosse, des inhumations isolées, dont
un crâne, montraient des traces de coups
et de décapitation. Un peu plus loin, un
crâne d’enfant de six ans est associé
à un crâne de cochon, une corne et un pot
en céramique.
Le corps sans tête de Jerf el Ahmar, qu’on
a déjà évoqué, gisant sur le sol du bâtiment
communautaire, est évidemment à rapprocher
d’un sacrifice. La mise en scène est impressionnante,
et 9 000 ans plus tard, elle glace toujours
le sang. La jeune femme décapitée a été
étendue par terre au centre de la pièce,
juste avant que le bâtiment ne soit détruit
et condamné. Pas de doute inspecteur, c’est
un homicide.
Ces découvertes exceptionnelles nous font
entrevoir des pratiques bien différentes
d’un simple rite funéraire. La décapitation
des squelettes a peut-être à voir avec des
sacrifices. De quoi, une nouvelle fois, revoir
l’interprétation de trouvailles anciennes
: la décapitation des figurines anthropomorphes,
souvent associée à des accidents de conservation,
aurait pu être une pratique volontaire, comme
pour mettre à mort symboliquement les statuettes
avant de les enterrer. La Dame aux fauves
de Çatal Höyük ou les nombreuses statues
d’Ain Ghazal à la tête mutilée seraient
dès lors des imitations de ces rituels meurtriers...
Des pratiques superposées ?
Au terme de cette explication, il faut bien
avouer que ces symboles conservent une bonne
part de mystère. Finalement, vous le voyez
venir, il n’y a pas de réponse définitive.
En fonction des cas, il est même possible
que les quatre pratiques qu’on a décrites
aient cohabité, car elles sont chacune étayées
par des trouvailles archéologiques solides.
Il a vraisemblablement coexisté des pratiques
concernant les ancêtres et les ennemis. Les
crânes retrouvés avec leur mandibule et
leur première vertèbre toujours en place
ont été décapités avant décomposition,
sans doute sur des ennemis, tandis que les
squelettes trouvés avec leur mâchoire mais
sans crâne montrent qu’il a été prélevé
bien après décomposition, sans doute sur
des ancêtres. Il y a au moins deux pratiques
qui se superposent.
Et puis, il n’est pas à exclure qu’on
y comprenne rien ou presque. SI ça se trouve,
on mélange tout. Vu depuis le XXIe siècle
après J.-C., avec seulement quelques dizaines
de sites archéologiques à se mettre sous
la dent, le symbole des crânes et des vautours
nous semble avoir une signification unique
pendant 4000 ans, mais c’est peut-être
un biais dans nos sources archéologiques
ou une erreur d’interprétation.
En tout cas la persistance de ce symbole dans
la très longue durée, fait penser qu’il
avait un ancrage mythologique. Les animaux
représentés sont relativement les mêmes
entre les sites de la région : serpent, renard,
panthère, aurochs… en y ajoutant les vautours
et les corps sans tête, il y a peut-être
là un récit cohérent, des éléments d’une
mythologie qui nous échappe, mais qui a structuré
pendant des millénaires l’imaginaire des premiers agriculteurs.
Et peut-être que de
nouvelles découvertes
nous en apprendront plus un de ces jours.
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo, merci
à mon équipe pour m’avoir aidée à la
réaliser ! Si vous voulez soutenir la chaîne
vous pouvez le faire via TIPEEE c’est sans
engagement et chaque don est précieux pour
me permettre de produire ces vidéos. Je vous
donne rdv dans 15 jours pour un nouvel épisode de
MiIIssioOOn AAArchéoO
d’ici là vous pouvez
me retrouver sur Instagram, TikTok et Twitch